こんにちは
ドクトゥゥゥゥゥゥゥゥ
(左)ぐわはっ
はじめだ
まじょまじょねるねる
本来の
あの...
ぶｈ
今回のまじょまじょねるねるは
新キャラがいますね
こちらのこの人
魔女さんということで
新キャラの魔女さんとこのバカみたいなやつで
今回はこの二匹でね
仲良く仲良くねるねるねるねを作っていくわけなんですけども...
あ、こいつはねるねって言う名前なのか
はいここ、名前があった。このバカみたいなやつはねるねという名前があるらしいですね
なにが普通のねるねるねるねと違うのかと言うと...
こちらに3つのキーワードがあるわけですよ
パチパチする!?
もっとふくらむ
味が変わる
これはね画期的としか言いようがないねるねるねるねですよ
今までのねるねるねるねは全て味の変化がなくね
おいしいんですけどもこういう特殊な効果はなかった
今回はそのエフェクト3つ加えたうえでの挑戦ということで
同じ三角カップに水を入れて
一の粉二の粉を入れてパチパチポン
はい
よくわからないが、とりあえずね
ぼくが今回目を付けたポイントは
もっと膨らむという点だ
このまじょまじょねるねる何故膨らむ事が出来るのかと言いますと
重層というね膨らし粉が入っているんですよ
重層には泡の元が入っていてレモンの酸と反応し
炭酸が出て膨らむらしいのでございます
そこで～～
ドクターはじめは考えたわけさ
そう、わたくし今回十袋位まじょまじょねるねるを準備したので
このまじょまじょねるべ...
もう...嫌になりそう...
ご視聴ありがとうございました
終わんねぇわ
このまじょまじょねるねるを十袋全部ここにブチ混んで
さらに！
こちら、炭酸水素ナトリウム、重層を準備しました
これはガチの重層です
うん...間違いない...大丈夫だ...
あーでもなんかやりすぎると死にそうだな...
なんかこういう薬系怖いからな...
でもやりすぎいると死ぬんだよね...
ま、死なない程度にやってみよう
よくわからないけど...
怖くなってくちゃった...
もう重層が入っているんだから
さらにそれにね重層を加える事によって
大爆発が起こるんじゃないかと思ったわけよ
というわけで今回は
ねるねるねるねを爆発させてみようと思います
これぞサイエンテフィック(?)
普通に食べたい...
あの、真似すんなよ？
重層はね食用だから危なくはないけど
多量接種は危険な薬品なんで
はいというわけで早速一袋作っていきましょう
まず実際に作ってどんな感じなのかを試してみたいと思っている
まぁ至ってシンプルだな
うわ...粉多くね？？
は？？
うわぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ
ってなるわけね
袋が五つあります
ドクターはじめとしてはこういう余分な作業は省いて省いて省いて効率的な実験をしていきたいわけなのだよ
まずは何だ
一番粉をトレーの丸い形に入れます
ここの三角カップ一杯の水を入れスプーンでよく混ぜよう
はーーい
猿でもできるわ、なめとんのか
わー！！間違えた
んでこの三角カップに水を入れてきてそれをここに入れます
これを入れてスプーンでよくかき混ぜよう
はーーい
あらまぁ...
次二番の粉を入れ色が変わるまでよく混ぜよう
りんご味のねるねるねるねが出来るらしいですね
あらら色が変わってきた
はいこれがとりあえずリンゴ味のねるねるねるね。早速食べてみよう
まぁまぁうまいかな...
ここで使うのがこの三つの粉らしいです。
味が変わる魔女の小袋
膨らむ小袋
パチパチする小袋
膨らむ方をねちょっととりあえず実験的に入れてみます
これで果たして膨らむかどうかなんすよ
たぶん今重層とその酸が反応してるんでまさに今膨らんでいる途中だと思われますが...
そんな変化なくね？
これだけで本当に...
水入れなきゃ(苦笑)
さぁどうでしょう？
多少はね量が多くなった気がします
でもまぁ...
こんなもんかな(苦笑)
甘いぜ、俺はこんなもんじゃねぇぞ
さらにこれを入れるとパチパチするらしいからね
うまい！！
毎回毎回思うんだけど、開封が面倒くさいんだよな
まずは一番の粉！
そいや、そいや、そいや、そいや、そいや、そいや、そいや、そいや、そいや
一の粉投入完了です
水！！適当に入れてきました
早く混ぜなきゃ！頑張って水！お前らの力はそんなもんじゃないはず...
もっともっと頑張れる！ね？
さぁ
出来る～出来る～君ならできる～
ほら！みんなも！元気に元気に～
出来る～出来る～君なら...
ちょっと待っておれヤバいぞバカな人...
次は二番の粉色が変わるまで入れて混ぜます
んっ～んっ～んっ～んっ～んっ～んっ～
よし...よしよしよし出来た出来たぞ
色が変わるまで混ぜれば多分いい感じだと...
あぁでも割と変わるんだ、はっきりわかるんだね
なかなか現時点で盛り上がっておるぞ
はい、大分色が変わってきました
コーラ味だ！
多分思ったんですけどもっと膨らむこっちの粉を先に入れると酸が反応しちゃって
こっちのガチの重層と反応する分の酸が無くなると僕は見たので
このもっと膨らむ魔女の粉は使いません！！
直接重層でいきます
反応できる量は決まってるんで
おぅら
なかなかいいツヤのなってきたじゃねぇか
パチパチの粉も入れときます
ファイヤ
痛っ...あれ...なんか飛んできたぞ今
は？今飛んできたよ？
うわ！待ってこれ飛んでくるの？そんなに強いか？
え、全部入れたらヤバいんじゃないんっすかこれ...
これ危ないよ...
痛っっっ！！痛...え、飛んでくるやっぱり！
え、怖！ヤバい、ちょっと待って待って...
うわっ...
うぅ～わっ、待って本当に怖い
あの...ガチで飛んでくるんですよ...
よし、こんなもんかな
一応全部混ぜ終わったのでこれで土台は完成です
ここから実際に重層をブチ混んでこれがどこまで膨らんで爆発出来るか
(手を叩く)
見どころですね
はっはっは～
おまえらガチのやつだからな？
重層を反応させるための水、準備しました
これを一気に入れてかき混ぜてどれだけ膨らむかです
早速やっていきましょう！
先にちょっと溶かしておこう
んっもうなんかヤバい...これちょっ入れすぎたかな...
まぁよい
では早速重層、投入したいと思います
では参る
スリー
トゥー
ワン
ファイヤ
え、やべ...硬...
重層硬...
これがどう反応するかですから、酸と
ここからが見どころだぞおまえら
きたぞ～どうなるどうなる～
まぁ...
こんなもんしょ...
味だよ味
味味
ぐかっか...
あれクソまずい...
うっ...くかかっっ...
ヴかかっっ...
うーわ...ヤバい...うえぇぇぇ...